in just the last seven years of
basketball this man has been able to do
the following a win in NCAA title began
the NBA all-rookie first team have three
all-nba first team appearances an NBA
all-star game MVP five NBA all-star
appearances and now just this past
season an NBA playoff series victory
he's the number one overall pick in the
2012 NBA Draft and has a basketball camp
in New Orleans set up for Monday July
30th and Tuesday July 31st and is also
in Los Angeles for the ten thousand mile
pit stop of the mobile one annual
protection 20k road trip he's none other
than New Orleans Pelican Anthony Davis
how are you Anthony
I like that well I got it from you you
know I got that text saying please say
every last word that you would say that
worked for you yeah okay great
how's life for you Anthony oh great it's
great like you said for this ten
thousand mile to the memorial protecting
twenty tables for us
mmm Oh second stop hearing LA so I'm
doing great
okay that's pause is that part of here
in LA does that stop also includes
saying hello to rage on Rondo in any way
shape think I'm doing think I'm busy
with this okay but what's that been like
for you with Rondo now here in Los
Angeles and boogie cousins now in in
Golden State what are your thoughts on
those subjects I think they did made the
right decision they still used at this
point for me
over 400 focus on the team we have now
and what we can do the business that's
where like we were last year and in
terms of doing that you know how how how
are you I guess continuing to improve
Anthony I mean what what needs to be
improved in your game best you can tell
everything of course I want to include a
three-point shot
playmaking the ability you know I think
you can make the ball handling it off
look nothing better leader stuff for my
team so all that stuff all work alone in
this summer it sounding it better be
ready and prepared for there's a ton of
students well in terms of you know
boogie now being an in Golden State a
lot of folks will just you know have
been saying that obviously you guys are
kentucky wildcats together and being New
Orleans pelicans together and that you
might not be too thrilled in the fact
that he's no longer on the team what
would you say to that anytime anyone
leave those things I'm not sad about it
but to tell my decision to keep them to
say you have a modern girl almond and
potato I that was the best this is a
sense Anthony Davis here on the Rich
Eisen show Coach Cal
how often do you speak with him still
Anthony all the time bring me Coach Cal
probably thought maybe I think for fog
later this no so we communicate all the
time see the real does great guy and
anytime you have the phone and you some
of our I found them or Paul and justice
the breezes he's always there for you
what sort of advice do you seek out from
him still and it's already been
depending on that time you know a lot
had to do with basketball uh-huh so
whether you're struggling or
how do you handle certain situations as
a leader or anything like that
see definitely one of the voices I try
to lean on and make sure that I get as
much as likes out of him as I can and
what he's done around the leave me there
and dance also on a college basketball
game and to me Davis here on the Rich
Eisen show uh you know what do you say
to those who say the season means
nothing because the Warriors are
unbeatable
how do you respond to that Anthony they
are beautiful God is moving at this year
only able to beat the water
I'm going to see this and another close
ball like a rocket last year as well so
oh they're definitely beatable you just
have to you know Thomas a boy threw
their rods when anybody touched shots
and little any place you can't get down
a good service all you gotta follow your
game plan whatever that might be
oh and kind of have to always play the
first game so their money what do you
what do you say then when you hear that
the best team that has a shot to beat
them would be the Rockets because
there's Chris Paul and there's harden
now they just got Carmelo for for a
league minimum and they won all those
games last year how do you say respond
to someone you know all these oh so what
we always have a shot
that's their r2 unit over impulse it'll
also we have a shot I'm gonna get my
Master's bounce a little replenishing so
who they saying it's the best name or
anything like that came to beat I was
out there for my sustain when it says
this that position to win basketball
games so I don't really care about what
anybody else pain or stuff like that so
I'm to me it's all white noise you know
they have to line up some swim the same
lines we do there at the end of the day
is whoever put the ball in the basket
more a couple more minutes left with
Anthony Davis of the New Orleans
pelicans here on the Rich Eisen show if
you could change a rule in the NBA what
would it be Anthony you could wave along
and have Adam silver silver change a
rule what would it be
yeah I don't like the rules it is now
all the way all the little you know
touchy styles you know that making to
the way it was contacting this second
day there's a lot of more contact so I
think God could call us all about us you
know TV tech sales right now oh so I'm
always probably things that you want an
armbar you want to put an armbar and
somebody's better maybe when I get mad
yeah like - like Mahorn
or lamb beer back in the day just armbar
somebody that's what you're looking for
that's all yeah okay
so tell me about your basketball camp in
New Orleans
and no it's at the University of New
Orleans and why are you doing this
Anthony yeah this is me I'm doing it um
you know I start playing Wallace I love
the city's try to get back as much as
possible go out there that these kids
however many kids there's hundred two
hundred um to come out it it's been a
couple hours with me line for me is
interact with those guys oh not every
day you get to hang out so was maybe
your role model idols not sure about him
or not for pretty sure a lot of them on
him and just our doctor and off teaching
the game like they have fun little
surprises and I just spent a couple
hours with was saying no see the smile
on their face okay that's it Anthony
Davis camps calm and then this road trip
that you're talking about the 20k road
trip halfway through it's real world
demonstration for the mobile one annual
protection what's this all about her
you're doing yeah stop other ten
thousand mile to stop all by the end of
a warning for sex when they roll through
okay la the second star things you Shana
no pool day you really don't need a
change role you know until 22,000 miles
so this is what it is and this type of
thoughts and all the mouth those we were
getting it done what's your football
team Anthony what's your job I'm a bad
girl got baby that Packers
why why Packers um so when I got into
football poorest picaros to
bears-packers on your letter not hate
about that but um my dad did six Bears
guys but I never was into football and
we're not forgetting so the Bears wasn't
really that good no I knew a big in
August and of course not no problem with
it is stretchy I know a lot of guys who
knew him
psychologist follows along and watching
click over time and fell in love with
the Packers so instead of saying I
understand that 508 years ago okay so do
you never tried football you ever tried
it out never I will look into the bigger
that was a nice little so you know I was
the okay nice all this fear to get hurt
you're here you're aware that Aaron
Rodgers is a part owner of the Bucs now
though right I am okay so if he's there
right you're taking on the Bucs and he's
sitting there courtside you're not gonna
you're not gonna lose focus are you okay
maybe after the game you know I had time
with something but don't ignore the game
I rarely lose focus
okay what about Packers vs Saints what
happened then Oh
Packer really they're not in that town I
mean even in New Orleans really yeah but
you didn't stutter yeah
doesn't mean breeze doesn't come to a
game is that you're seen by our game
okay that was on but yeah okay good
thing about it for us though yeah you go
to the football games you can you just
ain't stayin on the table so I'm either
in a suite or in the stands rocking but
I can't really see me like oh it'd be
good you know okay okay okay
interesting we don't know where it all
we're all lies down hey Anthony next
time you're in Los Angeles stop by here
in the studio stop by here please thank
you
you bet that's Anthony Davis at ant
Davis 23 on Twitter the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience